good morning believe nation today's
message is balanced between continuity
and change over the new Peter Drucker
one of the continuing and dominant
chords of my work have been the balance
between continuity and change and when
continuity's completely cut which was
what the Nazis did then graph disaster
but if continuity's becomes overwhelming
then you are at most AG nation and also
catastrophe I see two kinds of
entrepreneurs in the world I see the
entrepreneurs who are constantly trying
new things constantly changing
constantly getting bored and then you
never actually stick with something long
enough to see success with it you're so
busy doing the next thing and the next
thing the next thing that you don't
focus on anything for long enough to
actually get some momentum and some
revenue coming in with the other
entrepreneurs who the ones who find
something and just focus on it but then
often they never change at all they find
hey this is my formula this is what
worked for me and I don't want to try
anything new and I don't want to venture
outside my comfort zone and you find
that those entrepreneurs have a degree
of success but then they start to
stagnate they flatline they get bored
they stop innovating and their business
eventually starts to go down we're the
real secret the real success comes from
combining both things together combining
the continuity and combining the change
you find something that works you focus
on it for long enough to actually start
making some money and building something
around it and then you change it and
tweak it to continue growing with the
times that continue adapting to your
customers and continue to build and grow
a business that excites you that you're
learning from and that also puts a lot
of money in your pocket
value to your clients so the question of
the day today for you guys is are you
the kind of entrepreneur who just stays
focused and it's reluctant to change are
you the kind of entrepreneur who has a
DD and is jumping all over the place or
do you have some kind of balance I'm
really curious to find out leave it in
the comments below thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of in spresso